okay so i only have one bill cosby
question and that is how sick of bill
cosby questions are you
it's uh
you know
i mean that blew you up
okay
okay like i had my you know i had my
path before that
i mean it
it made
people wear me in a way that
right they wouldn't have
and
honestly i didn't like being found like
that by some people because it takes the
it the it takes the other stuff is sure
of mine isn't that in
the same tone
you know what i mean it was like i
haven't worked i was on my
second special at the time you know
working and had stuff it's just a
it's an interesting situation man it's
been going for a while like if i i
didn't know
that i'd still be
right yeah wow
i don't want to even get into it
is a
is a fair question yeah
where people starting to look at you is
like you're the take down comedian like
who you going to take down next or like
things like that i get those messages
sometimes like this is a good
get hannibal in a case
like hannibal he's out like what are you
going to do now oh yeah it was just
everything
yeah like this rolling thing of every
time i knew a new part yeah and then it
would be a new
new people that
find out about it did also get angry it
is it's interesting because now it's uh
you know right
it it makes a template for
how
some folks communicate with me on the
internet that's really what that is and
i've heard a bunch of different verb but
i know
it's either somebody else say this
yeah and but it's funny with people with
fresh anger
about it too
oh okay yeah yeah that's how i hurt this
version in
2014 you're this you this robot it's
it's probably similar to jim jeffery's
and his gun control bit
like uh
that'd be that that's that that blew up
and so he goes on tour and like half the
audience is there because of this like
woke like gun control thing and then
they get just like
yeah like right right we don't want to
say that
but yeah it's called stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude